freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
schärfe ist ist präsent hinten raus vor
die chicken teriyaki sehe ich mich fast
etwas anderen video wie ihr seht bin ich
qualität von fischers unglaublich gut
finde ich als einziges von allen bisher
haben jetzt also mädels richtig fragen
hier gerade in einem hotelzimmer ich bin
auch schon mit echt auch wenn wir
allem wirtschaft nicht so traurig so
ist wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr froh
eine kleine vasari augen ganz so gut
gerade irgendwie so also womit fangen
in berlin lara ist auch mit mir und ich
weiß halt mit abstand das teuerste ist
relativ früh bestellen heute aber sollte
der anlage also erstmal was sagst du zu
richtig so ganz krass so viel krasser
ich glaube dass es schmeckt ultra ultra
höre zu diesem besuch hier zum anlass
oder schlecht es
diese mario am tattag was ist so möglich
immer bock lachs nuss butter nigeria hat
der menge für das geld ist die ultra gut
etwas auszutesten was ich schon immer
auch sehr lecker und wirklich das ist so
gut wenn man das frisch im laden ist
ist drauf lag sondern das sei irgendwie
mal testen wollte ihr werdet schon im
das ist ein unfassbarer der christ
sowieso eine rasche noch drauf so dass
weil du hast ja auch gesehen das war
aus es ist halt schon wieder so ein ding
der fisch schmilzt wirklich im und das
das klingt krank nämlich auch einmal
gerichtet wo ich finde das will ich
titel gelesen haben das sushi von
zwar schon wieder so ein bisschen
ist so mehr so ein kunst ist so zu schön
gerade so ist so eine richtige 10 von 10
ist schon richtig richtig gut wenn die
ist das barbecue soße das ist wirklich
lucky für neun euro acht stück gucken
ausgehärtet und das hat auch sofort
steffen henssler spätestens als ich mein
ich musste eine andere nehmen okay guckt
rohkarossen rum afrika 3d briatore hat
textur es war nicht so trick so wie man
krass ich habe nicht damit gerechnet
video gemacht habe aus dem allgäu also
um wahr zu sein schon aber wenn man
wir mal den warenkorb an 109 euro
dass es so gut sein würde dachte schon
euch das noch mal leute unten dieser
aus dem letzten bau von stetten fenster
es von buchanan schade in jedem fall
überlegt wenn man das jetzt so ganz
mindestbestellwert 70 euro bekommen die
frittierte reiskuchen um drauf tun ata
schon längst gegessen
klassisch im normalen sushi containern
das ist bestimmt richtig gut welche
in köln kamen alle leute gesagt du musst
trotzdem eine ultra positive
hellboy will nämlich auch noch weil wie
extra teuer aber es ist wohl truckers
bekommen würde in diesem plastikboxen
ja wo carlo in 1 perfekt die avocado ist
mal das sushi essen das ist so krass und
mayonnaise lauchzwiebeln und fischrogen
überraschung ist es so lecker die kann
dann hätte man wahrscheinlich in einer
klingt so ein bisschen scharf sieht auch
ja heute ist es soweit ich werde mir
verschieben die rich brough muss ja auch
es zehn von zehn empfehlen ich würde
großen 123 von den achter rollt dann hat
sehr lecker aus sind sehr sehr schön
krass die vokabel ist so gut was sie
alters ist wirklich sehr sehr kann ich
jetzt großzügig durch die bestellen ich
auch den preis wieder bezahlen hat
ein rich häusern hier zu bestellen stadt
kreationen wenn man sich das hier alles
dass du sie nur vom geschmack merkt weil
habe gehört dass es auch ein bisschen
logischerweise jetzt nicht jeden tag
man freundlich zeigt das waren 22 große
mal ein bisschen sojasauce drüber das
wir haben planierte surimi avocado
mal anguckt sich halt wirklich wert
ins geld gehen soll die bestellung bei
sondern wenn irgendwie keine ahnung man
deine zähne gleiten einfach so dadurch
war ein bisschen schade dass wir kein
hübsch aus aber ich bin gespannt wie es
mittelgroße sophie boxen und dafür ist
wirkens text flambierten lachs
kleines schild haben dafür dass man also
dem sushi restaurant und wir gucken uns
sich einen schönen sonntag machte auch
bei uns ankommen wird jetzt sagen hier
also das muss man wirklich sagen
obendrüber mario und fischproben oder
es schon viel aber bei der präsentation
durch
entspannend so ganz gemütlich es ist
das gemeinsam angehen als aller erstes
bestellt so leute bestellung ist da die
zwischenfazit die zutaten die verwendet
bei dem wie es aussieht kann man es auch
kaviar sogar
mal auf die website so wir sind hier auf
einfach wie so eine shopping tüte
wirklich unfassbar gute social und ich
die drei stück kosten 13 auf 50 und 40
werden allerdings wird wenn man merkt
verzeihen finde ich also auch wenn es
bekommen so man über boutique oder so
auch hier wieder so mega auch regen
glaube ich würde mich wirklich also du
dass also wir natürlich auch zur
der homepage und das erste was uns an
jetzt geschmacklich gut ist dann ist das
sofort wieder passt so lecker als
hast es ja gerade gesagt würdest du
aber wenn so viel haben wir ungefähr
ladeneröffnung bestellt quasi
alles um sonne es gibt wirklich nichts
sagen auch nochmal
halt was für den besonderen anlass also
lacht flame twal juni geary mit trüffel
bezahlt kommen sie immer gemeinsam rein
dementsprechend ist halt auch alles so
unnormal war nämlich auch sachsen mit
frisch wie es nur frisch sein kann
lasst uns mal guckt euch das mal an
was mir nicht geschmeckt hat bisher und
dem obendrauf ein container crispy
vielleicht klingen auch noch des tages
zwei stück für 21 euro gar 2 gegen diese
leute man sieht finde ich wirklich dass
nuss mutter sieht erstmal mega klassisch
chicken relativ leicht dann haben wir
wir haben das beste kommt nach beste
nachgeliefert aber ich glaube die haben
ich sag's ich sag's wirklich auch wenn
da so eine besonders feine maserung drin
wirklich frischen zutaten es ist ultra
hier das und dann haben wir hier okay
ausfindig hat nichts besonderes ist
vielleicht auf jeden fall das teuerste
ist also wo ich schon sehr sehr gut aus
leute sagen uns immer aber ich irgendwie
lecker
reihe stechen für 21 euro schritt atmet
glaub das ist wie nat oder so oben drauf
21 eur 90 also das muss wirklich richtig
gesetz sind zwei drin frittiert wir
flachs maki steffen henssler lässt
das finde ich ja schon mal sehr cool das
finde ich immer neue höhepunkte und das
aber ansonsten ist auch die ganz normale
kennt man vielleicht von so kleinen
das ding ist aber gerade bei so einem
seifen oder so kleine schlechten
ist eine 10% deshalb wir dass uns weiter
gutes radio auch sein also 85 mio oder
negiere ist und mit der reichweite rein
haben ab habe wir haben schnittlauch
produkt ist es irgendwie interessant zu
das ist deutlich mehr fischen als reisen
schmecken dank fürs zuschauen und bist
wissen ob es das viele geld wert ist
einmal rein gedacht und hören erfolgs
tiffany redmond will sein und die
therapien klose das wird wahrscheinlich
so da die uni gießen ich weiß nicht ob
chris beard
weil 21 euro alter ich mach's fürs video
du nicht
es war ja so sein und mayonnaise aber
das ist normalerweise finde ich nicht so
ich liebe wirklich bisher an diesem so
und geschäftsausgaben war im kopf klar
ihr habt einen der reiz in den mag ich
ich mich würdig fühle weil ich erwarte
wahrscheinlich so spicy mario sara du
dass es so super hochqualitativ schön
so viel davon nachdem wir gerade
wir sicherheitshalber auch ein auge
fast so ungewöhnlich hart und ist jetzt
wirst das allen voran feiern
drauf legen was bestellt wird thun ag
kommentar das schlachtfeld wir haben es
angerichtet ist trotzdem so einfach und
wahrscheinlich naja ich bin gespannt ob
nicht so ganz weich gekochten werden
wachstum aegeri so gern ich mag auch am
überhaupt auf den wollen so drauf ist
bei allem einmal durch probiert also
jetzt aber erstmal nicht unbedingt
gut schmeckt so ist so richtig edel und
weil dass wir daraus macht dass ich
kaum noch ganz viel vor uns und
negativ auf aber ich finde auch das
liebsten eigentlich so wollten beispiel
nicht durchweichen aber juli also
sättigung
richtig cool aber schmeckt trotzdem
vollkommen recht also dax markiert das
die rich euro
einfach nur gut so und das ist was
krass wie viel lachs einfach drin das
wirklich es ist schon sehr sehr hübsch
irgendwie ist das ein flexi letzterer
besonderes auch so einem hohen niveau
soll es einfach e mails reis drin wenn
erwarte so viel von diesen validierung
das kann man nicht anders sagen also
wir häufiger wird das es so auch in der
ist das gefühl dream erreicht zu sein
schon irgendwie besonders wenn ich so
sowas muss auch kommen finde ich wenn
weil sie halt einfach so teuer sind dass
schmecken wird wo sie sehr cremig den
sterneküche das ist dann so anders ist
bestellen wir auch mal repariert sind
man für eine große portion zwei personen
axa drin und da ist hier so einen
um anders zu sein und dann vielleicht
ein besonderer moment
wir mit zehn einzelnen sushi stückchen
120 oder zeit dann muss das auch halt
quatsch wie cache 1 kristina kelek sieht
nicht mehr so gut schmeckt jedem aber
mega schön aussehen aber es ist schon
bei 42 euro das ist wirklich sehr sehr
ich glaube das schmeckt wirklich auch
so gut auch mit den frühlingszwiebeln
sehr sehr gutes liefer konzept oder ganz
jedem der gerne sushi mag
mit mario mit fischrogen das
teuer zu teuer ist werden wir sehen weil
einfach aufdecken 31
wirklich ich habe vor so was echt immer
gute qualität davon durch auf ihren
ja also wir haben jetzt die hellboy
so ein bisschen ehrfurcht zu weil es ist
preis haben ist erinnert mich alles ein
ok werden sie wirklich krass aus hier
so wertvoll sehr lecker aber nicht wo er
bisschen anders sushi-restaurant dass
ich mal in köln getestet habe auch den
lieferservice auch als ein bisschen
hochpreisiges auch konzeptionell
bisschen ähnlich aber gut vorstellen
dass das von steffen jetzt als erstes da
war der tiroler muss man auch mal testen
oder der name acht euro alter wo kostet
mit garnele prix mit einer tastatur aden
city trip to no theaters okay das sieht
sehr sehr krass aus aber zwischen bögen
sind habe ich fast bei 100 euro
crispy chicken teriyaki das kommt auch
[Musik]